hi there steve kaufman here um i did a
video on how i went about learning
japanese
uh which is someone asked for and now
someone has asked me to do a video on
how i went about learning cantonese
so here goes bear in mind that i lived
in hong kong from 68 to 70 two and a
half years
but my main task there was to learn
mandarin and then i worked in english
uh also my wife is a native speaker of
cantonese although she is
equally fluent in english and we have
always spoken english at home
however i heard cantonese
when i lived in hong kong and
every so often i would meet with my
wife's family members for
chinese dinner and i would hear a lot of
cantonese
and i could always say you know nehoma
and kato chen you know how how are you
how much money a few simple things like
that
however it is quite easy to live
surrounded by the la by a language and
simply not pay attention and not learn
it uh we see it all the time with
foreigners living in places like where i
have lived in hong kong or japan
because language learning as i always
say it comes down to
motivation time and then attentiveness
and i wasn't motivated to learn
cantonese i spent no time on it and i
wasn't really very attentive to what was
going on
this changed when about 11 years ago
for a variety of reasons
first of all i i was in a chinese
bookstore here and i happened to come
across a a series on on learning
cantonese
and i was leaving through it and it's
it's i have it here it's called
the it's called the musical approach to
learn cantonese published by novelty
publishers in hong kong
and there were two things in this set
that struck me not the musical approach
which made no sense to me at all but i'm
sure it works for some people
but he said two things in here he said
first of all that the tones in cantonese
or mandarin we have similar tones in
english and i think this is an important
point we use tones
for emphasis in sentences and we have
the same rising falling low middle high
tones that they have in cantonese and
the second thing he said was you don't
need nine tones part of the reason why i
was not motivated to learn cantonese
partly because i felt you know i've
learned the national language why do i
have to learn a regional language but
the second one was that everyone said
and particularly cantonese speakers
themselves would say it's very difficult
nine tones you can't learn it so here's
someone saying no there's only six tones
and he sort of illustrated the tones you
know low
flat
ah
low rising ah middle middle rising and
then high flat and then a falling down
and he numbered them from one to six
and
he had like in this thing here his
vocabulary bank he had
a bunch of of words where the characters
were there and of course i can read the
characters but it also had the uh
chinese
uh you know romanization call it with
the number of the tone so what i did
then was and so that was one thing that
happened the other thing that happened
was i became aware of the existence of a
thing called
minidisc players
and all of a sudden it was possible to
easily record people or record the radio
or any other source and carry this
around with you and store them so very
conveniently
and so these two things kind of get came
together at the same time so i went to
the chinese cultural center here in
vancouver and said can you please record
this book for me
uh my wife wouldn't do it we've uh we
are in english mostly so
uh
they recorded the characters like the
chinese the cantonese pronunciation and
i just spent a lot of time
a lot of time you can see that i've
marked it up in various places i spent a
lot of time listening and looking at it
because the whole trick is to get your
brain used to the
patterns of a new language in some cases
it's grammatical patterns in some cases
it's which words normally are used
together but in this case i had to get
my brain used to
what
certain chinese characters were when
pronounced
allah cantonese
so i started with this then i had other
people record stuff for me then i bought
every book i could find in the bookstore
and i re you know on learning cantonese
whatever there was as long as it
contained the audio
and the preferably the characters
although i probably had some that had no
characters but were possible with the
characters because i had to train my
brain to the cantonese sounds
with these chinese characters that i
already knew
so
within i would say two or three months i
was able to listen to the radio at first
with a lot of difficulty and of course
the disadvantage was that i didn't have
i didn't have transcripts for all this
stuff so it was more difficult than it
had to be you know we're going to
hopefully have cantonese at link and
then anyone can listen to it and can
read the can see the characters
but there were certain radio programs
that i really enjoyed and i would record
them on my mp3 player
uh there was a fellow called jiang mo
gay at one of the stations has a great
voice he's very entertaining to listen
to
and he says everything two or three
times it's his way of explaining he's
just one of these people that's a good
storyteller and a good explainer so i
would love listening to him
eventually i got to the point where i
could
call into these radio talk shows there
were two radio talk shows on
here on chinese radio two different
competing chinese radio stations they
were always on at five to six which is
when i was driving home so i would
listen to one or the other depending on
what the topic of conversation was
uh and i would record these again on my
mp3 player so pretty soon i had lots of
stuff to listen to not only while in the
car but while while you know exercising
or or doing anything else
and incidentally once on this one of
these talk shows they had a
they had invited raymond chan who was a
a federal politician a chinese-canadian
federal politician in fact a minister of
the government
and he was the representative for
richmond which is where i bought this
book by the way an area which has about
40
chinese residents
and um
so his he was on there saying you know
we chinese we must vote for chinese
because that way we'll have more power
as chinese
and everyone else does it and and he's
he's of course
he plays his whole multi-cultural card
here you know
which is where the ethnic groups try to
get the government to pay attention to
them not because they're a voter or a
worker or uh you know whatever other
interest taxpayer that they might have
pay attention to him as chinese
so that he wants that then he feels
would give him a lot of power and he
used the example of how the sikhs at the
time of the liberal party leadership
convention they threw their weight
entirely behind one candidate
jean-chretien who became prime minister
and as a result the sikhs in the form of
herb dollywall their leader they now
control all federal spending in british
columbia of course all of that is
nonsense but he's using that to try to
persuade people to vote for him so i
phone in
and i say you know that really doesn't
make a lot of sense because
you know we would never have a chinese
canadian
member of parliament if they rely only
on the chinese vote you've also got to
get your vote from other people and if
you're appealing to your chinese
electorate strictly on the basis of
ethnicity who else is going to vote for
you and he said to me
he said you're only saying that because
you're white is this the other thing the
ethnics they love to the politicians not
the average person but the politician
loves to play the you're a racist and
so anyway i recorded this on my mp3
player and i thought it's kind of an
interesting testimony of what some
politicians say in their own language
and speaking to their own ethnic group
that they don't tell the public at large
at any rate
so that was cantonese and um
this whole business of getting involved
with cantonese listening on my mp3
player
was a major reason why i got involved
with this whole link thing because while
i was listening to
uh
cantonese radio i was uh i uh the news i
discovered that a chinese immigrant had
arrived at vancouver airport and had his
life savings stolen
twenty thousand dollars or whatever it
might be
so and we were i i learned that he was a
a software engineer and because we were
building software for the wood industry
i said well we'll give him a job
uh either he works out then that's good
for both of us if it doesn't work out
we'll have helped him out a little bit
so i contacted him through success which
is a sort of chinese ethnic organization
here in vancouver
and so we hired him and he a very nice
guy
high toefl score
but couldn't communicate
so we started recording stuff for him
and we started link thinking of ways
that we could help him because he
already at some level spoke the language
but he didn't speak it well enough to
communicate as a professional
and so that then led into a program
called the linguist which was for
learning english exclusively which then
became link
in the end he went back to china
uh so but then so that got me into this
whole thing for the last 10 years i've
spent more time and effort and language
learning in the last 10 years than i did
in any similar period at any time
previously in my life
and of course now that i discovered the
joys of the uh minidis player for
cantonese then i started going after
korean which was my passion for six
months listening to a lot of stuff on my
minidisc player but i lost interest
because but there was just no
interesting content after you heard
about korean americans going to school
in seoul or you know the chuseok
festival or traffic is bad in seoul you
kind of lose interest after a while and
at that time we got involved with link
we brought in russian and there was a
lot of interesting content for russian
so
korea's kind of been put on the back
burner and of course the other thing
that's happened is that the uh the
minidisc player has ended up more or
less on the slag heap of of uh
historically you know of inventions
because it has been basically
uh made obsolete by the mp3 player and
by all of the technology the ipod and
itunes and all of the amazing things
that have developed ipad and shouldn't
just promote apple products but that
have developed over the last 10 years so
there you have it that's how i got
involved with cantonese and it was a
rather fateful uh you know involvement
in so far as what i've been up to for
the last little while so there you have
it if you have any questions uh please
don't hesitate to ask and i'll try to
answer them thank you bye for now